thanks for coming everybody so yes I'm
fortunate enough to have about a year at
POV to experiment and build things and
try different things so I'm gonna show
off some of the things that I've built
and will ask for your feedback there's a
couple of themes that you'll see kind of
throughout the work one is trying to
take the kind of expressive aesthetic
power that we have with kind of
traditional media whether it's through
you know the software tools like after
effects and and editing tools and things
like that and sort of all the kind of
work you put into something offline to
make it truly polished and expressive
you know you get the artist voice out
there trying to bring that same level of
ability to interactive mostly on the web
so but my first couple projects will
talk about that and the other is kind of
meeting the audience where they live
whether that's adapting to the device
they're on the time commitment that
they're prepared for the sort of level
of experience that they may have with
you know whatever the interactive kind
of components are and finally I think I
mean I'm interested in finding an analog
to the traditional media have these sort
of conventions that help orient the
audience to know where they are in space
and time and I think we don't quite have
that yet in interactive so I'm trying to
kind of develop some of that as well so
the first project I'm gonna show off is
this is one I've been working on since
before POV it's a few years old but I've
integrated into some of my work at POV
and this is a JavaScript library called
seriously j/s which is it aims to be
kind of the web equivalent of something
like After Effects it does video
post-processing and effects like that so
it's it starts with this sort of basic
library this is just a you know a color
pattern of different effects that we can
apply so this is an example
of a bleach bypass right and you can
kind of turn it up and turn it down and
you do things like you know exposure
adjust which is you know it's simple
effects and stuff like that
trying to use the get the camera working
here the camera is not working so anyway
we'll show that off later but it gets
more interesting when you start to kind
of apply it to video and combine the
effects so this is an example this is a
music video that was put out by the band
okay go and the actual video that's
coming into the browser looks like this
this is what gets downloaded from the
network the band put out there sort of
raw green screen footage and I can
process it in the browser so by
combining different effects I can create
these different moods so what this is
doing is it's um the it's all kind of
node based if you've ever seen like
quartz composer or nuke some software
like that every sort of node and then
you kind of create this graph of nodes
and each one is either a media source or
some kind of effect or an output point
and you can kind of combine these and
and chain up these different nodes so
what this is doing is it takes starts
off with this video of this band doing
things in front of a green screen and it
runs first it runs through a chroma key
filter then it runs through we kind of
composite that on top of this background
then convert it to black and white and
then run this kind of TV glitch effect
on it and each one of those is a
separate effect and it runs one on top
of the another and then if I change over
here to a different effect it's a
similar it takes that same chroma key
node and puts it on top of a different
background and then runs a different a
color effect it's kind of night-vision
effect and some scan lines and some
vignette around the edges I know and I
kind of go between them there's that
kind of Star Wars wipe effect right as
it's doing that it's kind of running the
two different chains of effects in
parallel and combining them up at the
end so this is using a technology called
WebGL which gives
access to the the graphics processor
which allows you to do a lot of really
kind of advanced things in parallel and
gives you these the ability to basically
edit high-definition video at 60 frames
per second in real time in the browser
see and the idea is that you can rather
than having to render this stuff offline
you know which if you can read it
offline you may as well render it
offline but you can render it as it goes
and react to what is the user doing or I
can bring in some new data or new video
clips or new images kind of right up to
the second that the person is watching
it so it's it's mostly kind of
experimental and it's a cool technology
and you know we're kind of continuing to
see what what uses does it have so I'll
show you something another kind of
experiment that we built with it at POV
which is to do these transition effects
so this is running a video clip again
this is all in a browser right and I can
switch between one video and another and
it runs this flash well let me this
should be playing
there you go so it runs this kind of
flash effect and we see that sometimes
on the videos pause because of network
issues but sometimes we see these flash
effects on I think they do it on like
ESPN and reality shows and things like
that so what this does is you you know
you switch between the videos whenever
the user wants to switch between the
videos or you know you can kind of pre
program that in based on preference or
let's say you want to have maybe a short
version of your video in a long version
of your video and it adapts to you know
what the user is doing so maybe you say
okay if I'm a mo on a mobile device
maybe we show them the short version
because you know it's likely they're on
the go or you know if I'm on a desktop
or like a giant screen maybe we show
them a long version
you kind of splice it as you go and say
we're gonna build in these transitions
and you could have the same level of
expressiveness that you would have if
somebody had done this in final cut or
After Effects offline and you can have
them online so there's a couple of other
different transitions that we built in
here so there's the wit pan which I like
and of course the channel change which
is my favorite always so yeah the
channel change uses the same TV glitch
effect that we used in the other demo
the flash it what it does is again
compositing multiple different effects
so we start off with you have your input
your your video that your you're
transitioning from and we ramped up a
blur and an exposure over the course of
maybe like a quarter of a second or an
eighth of a second and then switch to
another video and then bring the
exposure and the blur back down to zero
so it's it's the same kind of stuff that
you would do you know in traditional
editing but we do it in code and it
makes it much more adaptable so that's a
cool a cool toy what else the next one
comes back into the area of adapting to
the user so this was an idea I was very
frustrated with the way
the experience of watching videos either
in a browser or especially on a mobile
device where you ever seen when somebody
wants to show you a video they took on
their on their iPhone and they hold it
vertically and it's got these giant
black bars at the top and the bottom I'm
one of those people I always have to
grab it from the person and rotate it
and say please please just hold it right
and fill up the screen you know it
drives me nuts or even you know if you
see like if you if you're doing a web
experience and you have a video and you
want the video to fill the screen that
question of what do you do with it it's
it's tricky because you either have to
have black bars on the top or the bottom
or the side or you cut off chunks of the
video now if your subject of the video
is in the center of the video that's
fine okay so you cut off the sides you
cut off the top and the bottom okay
whatever it is but the one thing that to
me does not work is this assumption of
well I I should just think whoever's
gonna watch my interactive video webpage
should just always have let's close all
your other browser tabs and maximize the
thing and show it on a big screen like
that you know I think I think that's
disrespectful of the users experience I
think somebody maybe you know maybe they
read about your work on a blog and the
browser window looks super narrow like
that right and then you say oh well
sorry you have to maximize it I think
that's rude at best so I came up with
this idea of well I was remembering back
years ago with the little experience I
have shooting film and remembering the
time especially around sort of when we
were transitioning to the 4 by 3 TVs to
the widescreen TVs and used to kind of
have to shoot for both right you shoot
your you know so you'd have the the
guides when you're shooting and I
thought well what if the guides could be
different every time for every shot
because maybe one shot you wanna your
center of your screen is or your center
of focus is on the left side or another
shot your senator focus is on the right
side so I built this software that kind
of for each shot you get that that data
is specified along with it and the
cropping of the video reacts to it so
this shot for example I thought this
building on the right I'd want to keep
that in frame so when I so if I turn off
the effect right just the
traditional and we get these bars right
on the sides and if I go to skinny then
I get them on the top right but if I
turn on the effect it fills the screen
and as I close it as I shrink it it
keeps the right side of the frame in in
frame and it crops on the left side
because the left side is extra right and
if I play into the next shot next shot I
thought well this bridge part here is
the most interesting so as I narrow it
like that I keep the bridge in the frame
or if I go kind of up like that I
figured this wall kind of would that
tells the story best so this video clip
has a bunch of shots again with this one
we keep we keep our subjects in the
frame whichever way I do it I know I
lost come on so we can do this shot by
shot
and the next let's fast-forward a little
bit we can even kind of animate it which
I think gets interesting so here's this
bit where this this is from a POV film
cutie in the box or will be coming out
in our next season keep an eye out and
so he's gonna kind of walk across this
frame filling up this painting as he
goes right which so if I'm gonna watch
this in full screen like that this is
just more or less the original shot it's
fine it's great but if I narrow it down
if I think all right I'm watching this
on say a vertical tablet right it's
actually gonna pan with him as he goes
you can see it moves really slowly so
something I learned from this which was
interesting is that I do have to pan
really really slowly otherwise you can
kind of see that pan and scan effect
because if I had if let's say I had the
camera on a track and we were moving the
camera there'd be this sort of very
subtle kind of parallax difference that
you would see and if I moved it quickly
you would really see it so if it's not
quite as good as being on a track but if
you move it
slowly it's not going to different is
aren't going to jump out at you so this
you know and this adapts to a tablet it
adapts to not quite every phone but you
know it works pretty well now
something's gonna happen shortly so I
don't if you see the flashes on the side
so this is the boxer and QD is taking
pictures of him and it should in a
second it's gonna cut back to her see
there it goes
so it cuts back to her right and she
takes a picture and then it's gonna cut
back to him okay great so but they're in
the same shot right so if I were to do
this if I if I had to frame like that
and we wanted to cut back to her it's
not really enough of a cut right you
just it would just sort of jerk a little
bit in the middle so it's intelligent
enough so I tell it for that shot only
apply that that cut if it's within a
certain aspect ratio so if I go back and
play it again it just it just continues
to kind of pan across so again this is
another scenario where you know III
think that sometimes I get some
resistance from filmmakers on this they
say look I frame the shot the way I
framed the shot you know deal with it
watch the way you want to watch it and I
think that's kind of the traditional
approach is we assume that people have
nothing to do on a Friday night and
they're gonna go to the cinema because
you know what else are you gonna do but
we know they have other choices and I
guess the kind of statement I'm saying
is like yes it is ideal if people watch
it the way you want them to watch it but
audiences can be picky now so if they're
gonna watch it the way they want to
watch it you should at least have some
control over that right rather than you
know I think I think the worst scenarios
is just saying you know I'm gonna hold
my phone vertically and have Jesus dine
at black bars or we're gonna cut off
half of somebody's face in this shot so
I think this is a good kind of
compromise on what at worse it's a good
compromise of making serving both the
artist and the audience and I think it's
best if you can shoot the the film with
this in mind I mean this is we happen to
be luck
that we found a cool clip that it works
with but it doesn't work with every clip
and it's I'm destructive no no this is
the beginning of the film and the
filmmaker was cool enough that yeah to
let me do it
this is this is actually an example
where it gets a little bit tricky
because we don't want to cut off the
title so I do I sort of sew it for every
shot I essentially draw a rectangle
around what is the most critical part of
the shot and it will keep that rectangle
as close to center as possible or
inflate frame so you know outside of
that sort of temporarily outside of that
it'll let you be right so here so yeah
so that part that's it's one of my
favorites okay do have any questions
while we're going or anything that's
about three minutes that's the longest
one I've done
now I would love to see that yeah yeah I
mean would it would you do that to a
like an hour and a half long or an hour
long documentary I mean I don't see why
not wait you know we haven't really
built out the authoring tools for it the
authoring tool is basically I edit the
JavaScript by hand I had to go through
that shot you know frame by frame
yeah it's it was the kind of thing where
you know give this was an experiment to
see if people liked it and if somebody
wants to use it then okay we look into
building the authoring tools for it but
yes you you could do that yeah yeah
there there are there are algorithms for
taking an image and sort of finding
parts of it that are of interest and I
think the way that would work is you
could say I would do it once offline and
kind of run a first pass at it and say
you know here's my video let's find all
the interesting stuff and then output
the kind of first draft and then I would
go back and have a human tweak it I
think
I mean the way I imagine it is you know
I mean I think I imagine some
intermediate steps I think I think you
know if this were to if people were to
want to do this I would think you would
probably want to do something like this
Internet it's sweet you'd have an editor
doing it
and it would be part of that you know
maybe like a Final Cut plug-in or
something and it would output the data
file and you'd upload it to web and but
I think ultimately if it was the sort of
thing that was going to become standard
I think you would want to have this in
mind as you're shooting to whatever
degree is possible I mean if you're in
the field and a documentary I think it
would probably be easier in a studio or
in a sort of fictional film you know we
have a little more time and you're in
your shooting schedule but ideally yeah
if you were gonna shoot something and
you had time for a set up I would I
would keep that in mind when composing
the shot the same way they did when you
know when you had to shoot TV for four
by three and they said okay but the DVD
is gonna be like this so you keep that
in mind when you're shooting it you know
you kind of build in you know if you're
doing like a talking head for example
you say alright I want to I know that
somebody's gonna watch this vertically
on a tablet and somebody's gonna watch
it horizontally on the TV and who knows
what for a bread browser right like a
desktop browser now you have another
question
um yeah that's that's interesting
I mean shooting a close-up that that
fills the whole screen that would be
that would be challenging I think it's
up to the sort of artist to whether or
not they want to do I mean you you know
you can still have a shot that says okay
this shot needs to you need to have the
whole thing so if somebody's watching it
holding their iPad vertically you're
gonna get the black bars at the top and
the bottom and if that's the best way to
do it that's the best way to do it
that's okay you know or you say okay I'm
gonna build you know I'm gonna build it
in
I'm gonna build in that extra space you
know another thing I see all the time is
like on TV news when they like to show a
you know somebody shot their video you
know on a vertical cell phone like that
and they so they they put it in the
middle and they kind of blur out the
sides right you've seen that right they
have a second image behind it and that
feels sort of hacky and it's like okay
but what are you gonna do because this
is primary source footage of somebody
else who holds their phone vertically
which I begged people not to do all the
time but um you know you work with you
got what you got or you know if you have
the if you have the time then then I
think it's best to kind of plan it that
way
yeah
right okay
yeah talk to my agent cool yeah I've
also thought that I haven't tried this
yet but one idea was was also even if
the aspect ratio doesn't change maybe
taking into account the size of the
device too you know you might have for
example if there's a shot that requires
a certain amount of detail right and if
you're showing it on a big screen like
that you know I can have maybe a small
thing in the middle with a lot of detail
in it but if it's on a very small device
maybe even though the aspect ratio is
the same you might want to zoom in more
so that might be an area for future
research as well do custon well I I have
not but so this uses so I think if
you're gonna do something like this you
would you would render there subtitles
dynamically so this is something that I
had done in other work so this uses
since totally custom software for
managing the aspect ratios but it uses
popcorn j/s for the timing which is a
JavaScript library comes out of Mozilla
for running different effects at
different times on video and you know
I've used that for subtitles as well so
I think you know this is the sort of
thing yeah once if you're gonna do
something like that
I would absolutely dynamically render
the the subtitles in HTML and that will
allow it to adapt to that it does get a
little tricky with like you know the the
contrast between the subtitles in the
picture and so you have to do something
that's going to be it yeah that's gonna
be adaptable to that and there's there's
different approaches you can take
but yeah I think I would not want to do
it with something that has burned in
subtitles yeah
right right but the dynamic subtitles
has has so many other benefits anyway
you know like I did a project a few
years ago where we had it was like part
of it people were speaking English and
part of it people were speaking German
and part of it people were speaking I
don't know French or something and so we
had like if your audience
speaks German like we would the browser
would auto detect your language so if
your language is German we would only
show the English subtitles and the
French subtitles if your audience was
you know Spanish we'd show all the
subtitles right or if your audience was
German but they could turn on like
captions for you know hearing-impaired
or whatever we could turn it all on so
you get a lot more sort of finer grained
control you know you could also adjust
the size of the subtitles if the
audience wants it bigger or smaller and
things like that so there's a whole lot
of other benefits to that as well it's
cool so why don't I move on to the next
one so let's see we got here okay so the
next thing the next batch of stuff we
get into we start to get into virtual
reality so this is something else we've
been experimenting with over the last
several months so you guys probably all
I've heard some of you talking about it
as everybody is already fairly up to
date on what's going on with with this
thing yeah who's tried on one of these
okay we got a few not not quite
everybody
I recommended trying it you have one at
home so so so virtual reality is is hot
right now for the last year or two you
know the oculus rift is a work in
progress and and there's some other
devices coming out at much lower prices
and they've historically been we're
talking in the area of hundreds of
dollars as opposed to tens of thousands
of dollars so and and cardboard yes
we'll get to cardboard don't worry
that's coming
and right so so it's getting better and
better and better and and a lot of work
is going into the visual quality but a
couple of things that are sort of left
out one of them among them that people
are really struggling with is how do you
interact with stuff you know I can put
this thing on your head and you can look
around and then you go well what do I do
and people have been sort of starting
off with some of the same interaction
models from kind of like you know
first-person shooter video games things
like that and I find that they I'm
really frustrated with them they don't
work at all so the first experiment
which come on browser so I should I'll
give you well I'm dealing with this I'll
give you another kind of bit of talk
about this so a lot of people are using
video game engines to build to build
work for virtual reality so there's
there tends to be sort of two approaches
right you either have you build
something like a video game where you
model this 3d world and you put the user
in the middle of it right that's that's
one approach and the another approach is
you get these fancy camera rigs with
many many cameras around in a circle and
you kind of you shoot video in
synchronization synchronized in all
these multiple cameras and then you
stitch them together in this horrible
complex format that supposedly makes it
3d so that is interesting and there's
some good stuff happening there it's got
some limitations and the process for
both is difficult do you have a question
already oh okay oh hi okay um that's
alright um let me restart so the reason
I'm having so much trouble with this
browser right here
is that there's a another approach to
delivery of this content which is
delivering it in a browser as opposed to
a game engine and where this is bit
interesting is that so the native
of game engines they're pretty fast and
you get these really high frame rates
and low latency so late when I say
latency I mean as you you move this
thing there needs to be like less than
20 milliseconds for each frame each
frame needs to be less than 20-some
milliseconds about behind where the
actual position of your head is more
than that east a little bit more than
that it starts to like not quite look
real a lot more than that you start to
get sick which is a whole other
interesting thing is that you know I've
been working with bugs and software for
years but this is the first time where a
bug in my software can make you carsick
for like two hours
so that's this just a new thing I'm
learning about the process so anyway so
the browser is an interesting delivery
platform because it does a couple of
things one is that it
so yes the the the latency is a little
bit longer and the frame rate is not
quite as high but one is it it's a
really great delivery form because if
you're gonna get something that's built
in a game engine usually have to go and
you download some file and it's 500
megabytes a gigabyte right whether it's
on your phone or your laptop and you got
to like wait and you download this thing
and then you run it and who knows what
software you're running on your computer
it could you know have security issues
it could be buggy it could take over
your laptop or do do whatever it right
whereas on a browser you bring it up you
know you load the page and it's just
it's there within less than a second if
you have the available bandwidth right
yes yeah
right but what you can do and you could
do this in a native app as well but it's
a lot harder is you can you can build it
to sort of gradually display you know
you can you can write you can bootstrap
your basic scene and your head tracking
immediately and then fill in the scene
as it goes which we do some of that in
another demo and the other thing that's
good about it and I'll get more into
this in a little bit is that it's a lot
more adaptable like you know browser
runs on so many different platforms and
we can build something that you know if
you say oh I need to run some Unity game
engine thing and it's gonna be geared
okay I have to have the oculus rift and
I have to have a fast computer and it
has to be on this and you know you have
to send out the PC version is like oh I
didn't make a Mac version let me see if
I can make a Mac version right so this
can work you know if I have the headset
if I don't have the headset if it's a
phone if it's a tablet if it's a laptop
as long as it's a relatively recent
browser it works fine so the first
interesting experiment we built with
this is to go back and address that
question of whether of how do we
navigate and control stuff so let me
make sure I'm on the Wi-Fi here so this
is a fun trick so I can look around
right and I can even I can look around
in 3d right ok so that's all good but
how do I move around so one of things
that happens so Unity game engine for
example has this kind of built-in
controls for moving around based on what
you would do in a first-person shooter
and the way it usually works is whatever
direction you're looking you use the
keys the arrow keys on the laptop or a
desktop whatever and whatever direction
you're looking is forward right now this
is passable but it stinks right the
majority of all the any virtual reality
piece you've seen out there that lets
you move at all does this and it's
totally unnatural because nobody moves
like that right so imagine Shawn and I
were right right exactly oh you know who
does it Batman
Batman does it because if you ever
looked at all the Batman movies before
the Dark Knight he can't turn his head
so he always got to do it's got to do
that next time you watch Batman anytime
any was you gonna see it all the Michael
Keaton was alright anyway so right so
that's that's
thing is like if I'm if Shawn and I are
walking down the street and we're gonna
talk to each other I'm gonna turn and
talk look at him as we're walking and
I'm gonna check in every so often make
sure I didn't step into traffic but for
the most part I'm kind of turning my
head but imagine Shawn and I were
walking down the street and I look at
him and I just start walking into him
just like that it's totally unnatural
and it really just throws you off so I
was like maybe we can do better so I
figured I've got this thing right and
this thing has an internet connection
it's got a touchscreen it's got an
accelerometer in it so what I do is I
scan this I know QR codes are cliche but
bear with me so I look feel like I'm
connected so now let me get centered I
can point at things and so I can it's
tracking where I'm pointing it so I can
grab stuff so I grabbed this cow right
and I just tap on it and now I'm moving
the cow as I move my phone right so
that's kind of cool so I tap it again
and I can I can grab any of these
objects and manipulating manipulate them
which is pretty cool and it also does a
little thing which as I hover over each
object I get like a tiny little
vibration in my hand so it's a little
bit of kind of feedback that way which
is neat and the other thing is so now
how do I move around so I can just kind
of drive like this right and wherever I
point my phone that's where I go so I
can either do it by pointing my phone or
by moving my thumb in any direction so
if I put my thumb down and I move it
forward I'll move forward and if I move
my thumb to the right I'm just the right
but then if I rotate it my thumb is
still to the right so it's sort of it
works whichever way you do it and it's
better if you're kind of looking around
as you do it and it's pretty I think the
alignment got screwed up but it's pretty
natural there you go
the other thing that I do with it is
kind of neat after some experimenting so
there's there's this whole
best practices guide that oculus put out
that tells you what things make you sick
and what things don't make you sick and
the biggest and one of the big things
that makes you sick is moving backwards
or sideways so what this I had to do is
if I'm if I'm moving let me restart it
here and so if I'm moving forward I can
move forward pretty quickly but if I
look to the side it slows down quite a
bit or if I look backwards it's going
very very slowly so it's always kind of
tracking the difference in angle between
where you're moving and where you're
looking and it's and it's the fastest is
if you're walking straight ahead and it
slows down as that angle increases which
if you think about it is mostly how if
you don't walk you should encourage you
to walk that way anybody doing full
sprint backwards just please be very
careful so yeah so I feel like this was
a pretty cool experiment fairly
successful and that was cool so I took
the same thing and I used it in my next
experiment which I'm also kind of kind
of psyched about let's see so let's get
I'm gonna get this set up again okay so
this was getting into data visualization
a little bit so where this comes from
was again so if I go back and talk about
the way that people are making virtual
reality it's like you either have kind
of this these expensive and difficult to
use camera rigs which limit you to one
point of view to one spot or you have to
construct a 3d world more or less by
hand you know you can scan some things
but it's difficult and you need you need
to get the lighting right and you need
to have artists really constructing
these things and that's difficult and I
had neither an expensive camera ignore a
good 3d artist I'm certainly not one so
we I worked with some data here so what
I got was I used OpenStreetMaps has
these giant databases of buildings and
maps of most of the world like every
major city in the world so I can drop
you into Tokyo London
wherever you want this happens to be
Manhattan because that's where I live
and it's awesome and so we can fly
around and this works with this thing
too so I can get aligned so yeah I can
kind of fly Superman like all over New
York City and here's where this is uh so
this loads up progressively as well so
as I go I didn't load up the entire
world as much as I would like but as
I've screwed up my I better get my
alignment right here sometimes the the
orientation of the phone gets out of
whack so but anyway yeah as you as you
fly around the city progressively loads
up so that lets you keep a pretty high
frame rate without sorry every time this
is a thing if you're sitting in a chair
it becomes difficult to turn all the way
around so I just did a thing where you
shake the phone and it does it rotates
you 180 degrees so that's kind of neat
so anyway yeah so right so it loads up
progressively and it's cool what's that
yeah yeah yeah with with boxes over
their heads yeah okay so so the first
part the first part was just getting the
city rendered and that was that was
tough work and it's pretty cool and if
you can fly around it it's super fun and
weird but now what kind of data can we
bring in so first piece I got was income
data so this is from the United States
Census so we can go anywhere in the
United States and look around and we
charted income data so here in the upper
east side we've got some a lot of income
happening and if you look up in the
distance up in the Bronx some of these
bars are not so high so that's kind of
cool it's kind of excited about that we
did the same thing with bubbles
instead of bars we've got bars and we
got bubbles okay giant bubbles on the
Upper East Side it also happens that
this is like the best spot in the world
to see like disparity this is uptown
Manhattan what else okay here's where I
think it starts to get really
interesting so let me go back to the
beginning here so here I got this is the
a database of flu excuse me
this is each one of these is a personal
injury claim against the New York City
Police Department in 2013 so there's
something like 3,800 of them from that
year and I plotted them just all over
the city wherever they happened so here
I am on the Upper West Side and we fly
uptown I mean I they're from different
databases so this one right so the
buildings and the maps that's from
OpenStreetMaps
the income data is from the US Census
this is from the New York City some
Office of the Comptroller so there's
various data sources the census was a
good one got a lot of stuff from that so
as we fly up the Upper West Side we see
okay there's a couple of incidents here
the Upper East Side is a pretty safe
place a lot of wealthy people and I'm
surprised that there's even as many as
there are and then we start to get
uptown and of course what happens when
we get to the Bronx there's a lot
there's a lot in Brooklyn as well but
the Bronx is just it's totally lit up so
where this gets interesting I think is
we get uptown here we have this is kind
of flying up over the city a little bit
and I can do another view where I'm sort
of lower down right get closer to the
ground and as I kind of play around here
so I also we move a lot slower we're
close to the ground because it it just
makes you more sick fear faster that
that I you just crashing into buildings
or just super weird
but as you know I played with this a
little bit and I found myself as I was
sort of roaming around the city
I find myself imagining that and again
this is just these are just these big
red cylinders right you know is this
quick and dirty
visualization I had in mind like I
wanted to make it into like these fires
or like lit up spaces and make them more
maybe a little more expressive and
elegant but it's just just this clunky
example but I find myself trying to
avoid them trying to think can I walk
through a neighborhood without running
into a spot where this violence
supposedly happened where somebody was
presumably if somebody was injured by a
police officer and you can't like it's
just think about how many Starbucks
there are and it's like multiply it by
50 they're just they're everywhere you
walk around and this is where I think
the the kind of VR pays off where it's
different from you know plotting this on
a map because this somebody did plot
this on a map right and and that's how I
was inspired to try it and okay yeah
it's cool on a map but this feels very
different and and I discover there's
sort of this balance right when you
start off if you think about the map as
sort of the God's eye view right from
space of any data set you're you get
this you get tremendous overview you see
all of it right you can say okay there's
a lot going on here but there's not a
lot going on here and as you kind of
come lower into the space right and it's
sort of with the high flying high up as
sort of the middle ground as you come
lower the you sacrifice that overview
because you can't see what's going on
even three blocks away because there's
buildings in the way at least if you're
in a city with tall buildings and so you
sacrifice that but in exchange you kind
of get this a little bit more of a
feeling of intimacy and presence so I
think there's a lot of potential here I
think you know what I would ultimately
like to see is rather than just say okay
here's a city go explore it is a
narrative project where we kind of
alternate you say okay
we're gonna take you on a tour we're
gonna fly you around there's gonna be a
voiceover or something presenting here's
what the city looks like let's fly down
and you know as that go is gonna say
okay now you can explore when you've
been through that I want to show you one
more data visualization here which i
think is also pretty interesting so this
is population data sorted by race also
from the US census also inspired by a 2d
map that somebody do this so this is
interesting let's get back up to the
Upper East Side I should I just do Upper
East Side okay so there we go
so this actually looks even denser this
is what it looks like in 3d so the blue
dots are white people if anybody's ever
been in the Upper West Side Upper East
Side this is not surprising and as you
fly through it's sort of you know each
people are represented kind of like you
know as I think of them as like kind of
pollen in the air and see what happens
when we get uptown towards Spanish
Harlem you can imagine what will happen
sorry I'm crushing you through all these
buildings which is super weird and
people and it starts to look a little
bit different and once we get up - and
now it's pretty different you know this
this comes from some my own personal
experience sort of traveling the world
you go - you know I'm spoiled living in
Manhattan and we have there's quite a
bit of diversity you know but it does
vary by neighborhood and then you know
when I went to Copenhagen a few months
ago it was a little bit different so I
was trying to figure out like can i
replicate that experience a little bit
you know so it's not quite rendering
actual people and and they're still
abstracted but I think it does give you
the sense of like being there so that's
that's kind of neat so many questions
about that
No okay so we can move on I guess the
next thing okay
so as I was presenting this work in
Europe there was a I was on this panel
some a couple of you were there and
there was this discussion of diversity
in the field of virtual reality and we
were kind of worried that there was not
enough so far it happened to be a panel
of five men and you know we were looking
around at the industry and who's making
what and it's it's not great and that
got me thinking so somebody asked on the
panel they said well what about you know
how expensive is this stuff to make you
know can you you know do you need to be
super well-funded
to produce the Ericom you know content
and I was like oh well you know this is
only three hundred and fifty dollars
it's not so bad it used to be you know
we'd have to be thousands of dollars and
you'd have to have like you know super
computers everywhere and you know it's
really impossible and now you can get
this and you get Google cardboard you
guys know about this cardboard so this
is fun so oculus came up with this thing
and then Google came up with this thing
this is usually sells for about twenty
five dollars but you can get it for as
low as four and a half and you take your
phone and you drop it in and you put the
velcro on and you hold it up to your
face like that and it uses the gyroscope
in the phone to track where you're
looking right so now it's not as you
know it the latency is longer the frame
rates are lower but you can at least get
in it and it's really not that bad it's
pretty good
it's pretty cool so you know so I
started looking into it and I was like
well what kind of assumptions are we
making when I say oh don't worry this is
only $350 but I'm missing something here
I'm missing this this is like a twenty
three hundred dollar machine okay I'm
missing that I have to know where to get
this thing right I have to know where to
get the software for it and if I want to
build something for it well that's like
a whole other thing right so I started
thinking about the first thing I did was
some research into what would it take to
just like conserve you this content at a
minute
right so I found out I did some research
and I found out that something like 77
or 80 percent of people even under
making under thirty thousand dollars a
year in the United States people under
the age of thirty about eighty percent
have smartphones like not just flip
phones but like actual smart phones so
it's it's not that bad could definitely
be better definitely be better but even
you know I found that it is possible to
go buy a used not this one but like a
kind of low-end smartphone for about
forty five dollars that would be just
enough forty five dollars on one of
these for four dollars you can get in VR
for under $50 right so yes it could be
better but it's a start and that's good
and I think we need to be thinking about
that but that also raised the question
of okay what if you want to make
something what if you want to build
content and I still wasn't really
satisfied with that because you know
requires again thinking about like what
what are the assumptions so instead of
saying okay well I can build something
really easily because I have this
fancy-pants MacBook Pro and I have
hosting accounts and I have a computer
engineering degree and time you know at
POV to work on this stuff like what if I
didn't have any of that so I imagine a
you know fourteen-year-old kid who's got
you know
okay maybe they've got a smartphone but
they don't have a computer they don't
have a hosting account they don't have a
computer engineering background what do
they do right so maybe they go into a
public library or the school library you
say okay well I can get on the public
Wi-Fi with this thing so I don't have to
use my data plan that that is an issue
by the way as I was the last time I was
given this presentation a buddy of mine
was downloading the the Sun Sundance
that son is they released a bunch of VR
pieces and he was downloading clouds
over Sidra which is one gigabyte so he's
he's talking to me and he's got his
cardboard he's like oh this'll be cool
I'll set that to download and he puts it
down and I give my presentation and he
goes out to take a walk he sticks the
phone in his pocket and he gets off a
Wi-Fi right and he comes back and so
he's from Canada he comes back he's got
a text message that he's cost him a
hundred dollars in roaming fees for a
five minute walk and he's capped out his
plan for them
so this is something we try to be
careful of this is why we do this
adaptive streaming stuff like so you
know some thinking about other stuff so
this kid can get on on Wi-Fi and they
can sit down at the library computer now
what do we assume about these library
computers right so you can't install any
custom software on these things you know
you can't put the Unity game engine on
there right you can't you can't put like
a development you want to build an
Android app and you got to put on all
the Android development software right
you can't do that you can't even really
save files on them right you can save it
for five minutes and as soon as you get
up and log out it wipes off all the
files right so this is this you know
even if somebody has even if somebody
Santa Claus comes up with one of these
things like the kid can't use it the kid
can't make anything with it so what can
we do so I started with so this is a
jsbin does anybody know what that is
it's a so it's a it's a kind of a HTML
Javascript sandbox tool so it lets you
so if I make like just a new one here
yes Ben comm right well it helps if it
doesn't crash your browser that I can't
promise you so that this I'm by the way
I'm running an experimental version of
Chrome that interfaces with the oculus
rift and because it's an experimental
version it crashes all the time so
hopefully they'll fix that one day so
right jsbin so jsbin is this kind of
sandbox so it gives me some HTML on the
left and I can write hello wait maybe
hello and it shows up on the right and I
can make it into I can put some tags in
there right so I can type in HTML and
CSS and JavaScript on the left and it
builds a web page on the right so pretty
easy so what do we do is I start off
with this one and let me zoom in a
little bit so you can see it and all I
got to do is I paste in this script so
this is one script file that I built and
what it does is it bootstraps a VR scene
an empty VR scene with nothing in it on
the right side and we can pop this out
like that
okay and so far I got I got nothing
going on if anybody wants to bring this
up on their own machine you're welcome
to it's jsbin comm /w e m IP o-- / 1
so let's come back to that so now so
I've got the output so I'll get rid of
the HTML so now with that seen I can
start making some basic stuff so first
I'm gonna make a box so I type V R box
right and there's my box and actually if
I reload it should show up on here no
not so much
oh it's just number two yeah so yeah
jsbin so now as I even so now I've got
this box in my oculus and 3d right so
it's a it's a sample it's it's a the
script that bootstraps this scene it
works it works on it works just on a
browser right if I say I turn this off
and I can just look around with my mouth
like that if I don't have the device I
can use a device if I have it I can put
this on my phone and drop it into
cardboard right if I have cardboard
it'll do it in 3d if I don't have
cardboard I can just you know I can just
look around like that in one dimensional
or or I can scroll around with my
fingers it works on any of those so this
kid can this 14 year old kid that we
imagine this library can bring their
low-end smartphone sit in the library
build something there's a bunch of
commands so did see the v r dot floor
right so i've got a floor and i could
say i'm gonna make the box set material
wood right and let's move up to meters
x- one-meter move it over so there's a
bunch of commands for building simple
things that this what you can do is you
you don't have to have a hosting account
you don't have to have anything except
for the phone maybe you don't even
really need the phone you go to a
library you look up the reference for
these commands which are much more
simple then much simpler than most of
the 3d libraries out there and you build
something and you take that URL you post
it in your phone you send it to your
friends you send it out in social media
you send it to yourself and as long as
you have that URL you can come back to
it and edit again later anybody can fork
it so now this person is yes it's really
basic shapes yes it's lower quality
because it's on this dinky little cheap
phone and this piece of cardboard but
now we at least have this other range of
voices making content and getting it out
into the world and if they do get it out
in the world and they get it to somebody
like us and I have this thing I can look
at it in here and now this person is is
building things in in full proper VR so
that's that's the latest project and I'm
finding that as a sort of nice side
effect of looking at it from a point of
view of an audience that's very
different for me it happens to be I
think a pretty good prototyping tool as
well so you know it's it's for people
who have very basic JavaScript
skills like code Academy level they can
use it for a quick prototype you know or
if I'm sitting in a cafe with somebody
having a meeting and I left my oculus at
home and I'm like okay what would this
look like and let's sketch it out it's
like okay I get a floor over here in a
box over here in a sky over here and and
there's there's animation things I can
get them moving around and there's a
it'll play audio in 3d space and I can
look at something and it triggers the
audio or you know I can shake the phone
and it trigger something else you can
get something really basic going in a
couple of seconds even so I'm pretty
excited about that and you know
hopefully get some workshops going and
teach you some people to do it so that's
it for that one